talking of international careers ladies
and gentlemen let's not forget uh ant
and deck
huge international pop stars as pj oh
yeah
that that is bubbling up
that's horrible
[Applause]
you look like you're farting
[Laughter]
peter stringfellow
we had a very
small pop career for like three or four
years but it went it went far i mean
what i think it was
there's a story where i think
the big fame had gone but you had some
contractual obligations and you were in
indonesia yeah we had to go to jakarta
because we had to we had a few
contractual
gigs we had to play um
and like i said i call them gigs you you
just turn up at the hard rock cafe and
you'd kind of mime along to a couple of
songs and and the fans would be there
who
take the money and take the money and
get out of there
but we but we landed
when we landed in this place in jakarta
there was so we weren't that bothered
anymore we knew that we didn't want to
do it anymore we thought 23 and already
we want to concentrate on telly we love
doing um tv so when we get up to britain
that's what we're going to do yeah so we
thought we would
just turn up stay out everyone be polite
get out of there and we turn up and then
the guy from the record company says you
know you have to do like a press
conference the press are there
we we want you to meet them and then you
can talk to them and then of course you
can sing acapella and you give them a
song
what what
seem like capella
we have the backstreet boys here last
week and they sang a cappella for the
press is that yeah yes because they can
they can
we're not doing it yeah
and we can't so we said no we said we're
not going to sing our pillar we will go
and we'll chat i will answer any
questions
there's also let's get ready to rumble
we want you to do that yeah yeah
yeah the acapella for the press let's
get
so we said no and then on the walk down
there he was going please please do it
for them and we're like no and
it's they're just they're just depressed
there's like there'll be about 10 people
there or something they don't want to
hear that we don't want to do it so we
sit down
we're answering the questions it's all
going pretty well
yeah pretty much kind of wrapping itself
up nobody asks us to sing acapella we're
just about to leave the guy from the
record company says how about you sing
acapella what
we're like and then all the press go
yeah that would be good yeah let's do
that and we're like no no we'll come
back we'll do the show later
and they're like no no come on
so we said no we're not gonna do we're
not gonna we get up and we leave
the press corps start to boo us oh
in the press conference yeah what did
you do did you do it did you sing no i
almost started on the guy from the
record company
do you want to hear them do it now
[Applause]
come on we could easily do it let's get
ready to rumble
oh let's get ready to roll
get ready
hands
everybody
[Applause]
[Music]